[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce sens public
l'émission qui donne du sens à
l'actualité qui se met au service des
citoyens nous sommes le jeudi 22
septembre et nous sommes ensemble pour
une heure et demie de débats et de
décryptage au sommaire ce soir y at il
une méthode borne aux quatre mois après
sa nomination à matignon la première
ministre est elle parvenue à imprimer
son style des chantiers des réformes
difficiles l'attendent budget retrait de
transition écologique alors ce
gouvernement sans majorité va-t-il
pouvoir gouverner comme il l'entend ce
sera le thème de notre premier débat à
notre second débat sera consacré à cette
inquiétude qui saisit tous les
économistes de la planète sommes-nous à
la veille d'une récession mondiale aux
états unis en chine en europe tous les
voyants sont passés du rouge au vert en
moins d'un an
la faute à la guerre en ukraine bien sûr
mais pas seulement alors nous ferons le
point sur les causes de ce coup de froid
généralisée mais aussi sur les remèdes
avec nos experts mais tout de suite
place à notre premier débat elle
multiplie les consultations depuis hier
avec les présidents des groupes
parlementaires à la recherche d'un
introuvable compromis dont elle veut
faire sa marque de fabrique
au menu des discussions bien sûr la
brûlante réforme des retraites alors
elisabeth bornes peut-elle remporter son
pari c'est un sujet de jérôme ravier
ils étaient conviés pour évoquer tous
les chantiers de la rentrée mais c'est
bien le dossier brûlant des retraites
qui a occupé les présidents de groupes
parlementaires lors de leurs échanges
avec elisabeth bornes le gouvernement
tentera-t-il de faire passer cette
réforme par un amendement dans le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale ce serait une erreur pour le
patron de la droite sénatoriale je pense
que si si l'amendement le gouvernement
sans pales ras le meilleur véhicule se
serait un texte haddock un texte sur la
réforme des retraites qu'ils puissent
être concertée avec les syndicats avant
mais qu'ils puissent être ensuite votée
par le parlement mais puisque l'exécutif
a fait savoir que la nouvelle réforme
devait rentrer en vigueur en juillet
2023 ces soutiens puis plutôt sur
l'accélérateur comme l'a confirmé
françois patriat notre micro vous poser
ma question est ce qu'aujourd'hui les
sénateurs du groupe majoritaire sont
plutôt favorables à ce qu'ont avancé ce
qu'on avance vite oui c'est la position
du gratin à gauche des communistes aux
écologistes en passant par les
socialistes
tous s'accordent contre le principe même
de cette réforme est encore davantage
sur la méthode vouloir passer en force
d'une manière ou d'une autre amènerait
notre pays a contesté une manière
brutale et sûrement dans la rue une
réforme qui n'est ni souhaitable ni
utile une double fronde dans la rue et
au parlement qui pourrait faire vaciller
le gouvernement marine le pen a confirmé
aujourd'hui qu'elle voterait n'importe
quel motion de censure sur le sujet
si elisabeth bornes passe en force
fragilise encore davantage une majorité
relative en sus
le style bornes la méthode bornes
peut-être la surprise bornes on en parle
ce soir avec nos experts bonsoir
nathalie segaunes vous êtes joris
politiques à l'opinion sache accueillez
vos côtés bruno cautrès soir politologue
chercheur au cnrs et au cevipof à vos
côtés jean daniel lévy vous êtes
directeur délégué de l'institut harris
interactive france et puis laetitia cre
pas consommer chroniqueuse politique qui
m'accompagnera tout au long de cette
émission pour commencer ce débat je
voudrais faire un rapide tour de table
avec une question est-ce que elisabeth
bornes qui avait été qualifié de plan b
quand elle a été nommée est aujourd'hui
devenu un plan à oui non ou pas encore
selon daniel déjà objectivement c'est un
plan b parce qu'en fait c'était pas le
premier choix de d'emmanuel macron qui
s'orientaient vers catherine vautrin et
notamment du fait de la pression d'une
partie de son entourage au premier rang
desquels on peut parler de monsieur
ferrand où monsieur castaner il a changé
d'avis en tout cas pris l'option et qui
était de d'elisabeth bandes et les
événements quand elle est arrivée quand
même
elle a eu un passé on a identifié par la
suite quand bien même elle a été
ministre n'était pas tellement clown
connu en fait de la part de nos
compatriotes et quand on voyait les
traits d'image en fait qu'ils étaient
ceux d'elisabeth bornes globalement
c'était une personne qui avait été nommé
par emmanuel macron et une femme mais la
dimension de contenu politique la
dimension d'histoire politique voire
même le fait qu'elle ait un passé issu
de la gauche n'a pas du tout été
identifiés de la part de nos
compatriotes lorsqu'elle a pris ses
fonctions à matignon donc elles
resteront encore un plan b j'attends la
prochaine question maintenant
oui balaie la vesle apparaissait comme
une techno qui n'est pas vraiment une
politique dans pour les pour les
français les français qui l'identifié
qui réussissait à les identifier et tout
ce qui ressortait des portraits à
l'époque c'était ça c'était la techno
froide rigide et c'est parce qu'on la
connaissait pas je pense qu emmanuel
macron lui la connaissaient puisqu'ils à
exclure expérimenté quand même pendant
cinq ans c'est quelqu'un qui a un qui a
de l'autorité
dans tous les postes où elle est passée
c'est incontestable qui a des
convictions
et qui comme on dirait la l1 peut
hériter du sérieux jospiniste là elle a
fait ses armes dans le cabinet de
l'auto-moto choses pas à l'éducation et
ensuite à matignon donc elle a appris l
a appris
elle a aussi enfin c'est ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui elle est quand même attaché
et dans tous les postes où elle est
passée elle a fait elle a eu à coeur de
faire de la concertation du dialogue que
ce soit sur la réforme
mais vous d'eric depuis depuis quatre
mois du coup ça y est c'est fait le job
oui je pense qu'elle a pris ses marques
elle est finalement elle apparaît plus
politique qu'on ne le pensait moi je la
trouve plutôt habile
si elle fait je pense que du point de
vue des manuels macron elle fait le job
bruno cautrès bplus toujours plombés en
progression on va dire qu'elle a réussi
qu est ce qu elle a raté de +4 elle n'a
pas réussi je rejoins jean d'anevia n'a
pas réussi à imposer une image fortement
identifiés dans l'opinion de créer un
phénomène d'opinion autour de sa
personne ont dit ah bah ça c'est
vraiment le style borne pour le moment
je trouve qu'on n'a pas vraiment ça
j'avais regardé ça date d'il ya un mois
quand même alors peut-être les choses
ont changé une question vert qui était
posée par un sondeur sur l'image des
leaders nous font c'était assez simple
dans le coeur de cible des sympathisants
de la majorité présidentielle on
souligne son sérieux sa maîtrise des
dossiers son dévouement c'est quelqu'un
qui bosse wallace et l'image qu'elle a
quelqu'un de sérieux de compétent kg
sont opposés c'est très positif mais
auprès de gens qui ont une image
positive dans le camp opposé c'est
l'ombre des manuels macron c'est
emmanuel macron d'une autre manière
c'est lui le patron c'est lui qui
commande c'est lui qui lui disent
qu'elle doit faire ce qu'elle doit ce
qu'elle doit faire l'annoncé pas
nécessairement antinomiques et puis une
partie de l'opinion pour qu'ils
réalisent à bad bonn reste un peu un
point d'interrogation qui est qui est
cette personne d'où elle vient voilà
elle était totalement inconnu malgré
qu'elle ait occupé des fonctions dans
les précédents gouvernements elle était
quand même très largement inconnu et
donc c'est pour ça que je mets un bep
plus parce qu'on voit qu'une marge de
progression aussi pour elle dans
l'opinion d'imposer un peu plus son
équation personnelle qui elle est
vraiment être là qu'elle montre aux
français ce que c'est que le style de
gouvernement d'elisabeth dans quel
patron de gouvernement c'est canteloup
confrontés à des oppositions comment
elle réagit quand on s'affronte elle
comment elle réagit voilà des des
indicateurs sur lequel les français
jugent un peu leur premier ministre leur
premier ministre l'a dit c'est ouais
mais je trouve qu'elle est parfaite pour
le poste je vais vous le démontrer après
en parler parce que vous avez vous êtes
branché les gazouis alors donc j'ai
vraiment revue toutes ses interviews
relu tous et je crois que son style elle
a imposé et je crois qu'elle est
parfaite pour le poste pour un président
comme emmanuel macron alors vous parler
du style laetitia roux parliez
d'autorité nathalie segaunes regarder
cette citation s'était tiré d'un article
du monde paru hier élisabeth bornel 30
chaque étape et quand elle est prête
elle dégaine on craint plus une borne qu
un matou qui fait la une du parisien
avec une punchline elle prend de la
puissance de feu et elle vous attend un
proche d'olivier ferrand porte-parole de
gouvernement ça vous étonne non pas du
tout cette phrase je pense que c'est
effectivement elle elle et elle a quand
même réussi à quasiment il flingue va
désigner elle a quand même réussi à
contraindre depuis quatre mois
bono le maire et damanaki ont voulu lui
montrer de quel bois il se chauffe et
qu'elle était pas
qu'ils étaient enfin ait eu quand même
des petits bras de fer sur certains
sujets là réussie aller à les contenir à
contenir le
on voit qu'il ya tout le temps une
elfe et une conférence une émission
importante de radio télé lundi matin le
jour où est présenté le budget qui est
normalement dévolu
au ministre de l'économie marque son
territoire il se fait respecter
elle a quand même fait une campagne pour
se faire connaître pendant une semaine
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez au
début de l'été où elle a été sur tous
les médias pendant cinq jours et elle a
réussi à s'imposer alors que tout le
monde disait emmanuel macron bas
s'étaient tus après législatif va
changer de premier ministre et elle y
est allée je pense que c'est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement déterminer quand elle veut
quelque chose elle réussit à la voir
elle est très accrocheuse justement par
la communication natty c'est votre
moment de par nous parler de la
communication que vous avez vous avez
regardé de près la communication
d'elisabeth board qu'est ce que vous en
avez retenu depuis quatre matches accès
une jean castex au féminin bien sûr et
sans l'accent est donc c'est aller
vraiment au service des objectifs du
président de la république elle est à sa
tâche elle le répète et je crois qu'elle
l'a suffisamment martelé au cours de
toutes les interviews qu'elle a donnée
elle dit toujours que elle est à
l'écouté des français et qu'elle va
aller au contact des français mais il ya
une petite particularité qui lui est
propre et ça l a annoncé dès sa
nomination quatre jours après elle est
sur le plateau du 20 heures de tf1 face
à anne claire coudray écoutez bien je
dois tout à la république en fait et
j'ai à coeur de rendre à mon pays ce
qu'il a pu m'apporter
voilà cette dette à son pays c'est un
trait caractéristique d'elisabeth bornes
et c'est dans son storytelling vous
savez l'histoire que l'on raconte pour
faire connaître une personne c'est
fondamental et c'est son histoire et
elle a raconté son histoire à l'envi
dans toutes les interviews elle a dit
qu'elle était pupille de la nation que
grâce à polytechnique à la vega et de
l'argent et donc oui elle a cette dette
envers le pays ces gens dit soir que
emmanuel macron adore et pourtant on en
parlait en atteignant parler elle a été
menacée d'être évincé complètement l été
après les législatives totalement parler
d'un autre chef de gouvernement et plus
en plus à sion elle était sûre sur un
siège éjectable tout le monde le savait
elle même et c'est pour ça qu'elle a
décidé de faire cette grande campagne de
communication
juste après qu emmanuel macron la
conforte à son poste le 5 juillet elle
retourne sur le plateau du 20 heures de
tf1 décidément dans ce gouvernement on
aime tf1 pour communiquer elle retourne
et elle sait après carrément lancé dans
une tournée médias vous avez raison tout
l'été alors je ne sais pas si je suis
exhaustive parce que je n'ai pas une
armée de stagiaires avec moi donc je les
fais tout seul avec mes petits yeux mes
petites mains j'en ai compté 12 des
interviews depuis sa nomination le 16
mai 10 dans l'été est alors avec un
spectre très large de la pqr comme
l'alsace jusqu'au au magazine têtu le
monde le parisien pour sa rentrée le 28
août donc vous voyez qu'elle a vraiment
bas elle balayé très très large et y
compris en avance sur un terrain qui est
toujours délicat oui exactement la vie
privée c'est en général chasse gardée et
on n'y va pas quand on est à un
politique d'autant plus quand on est à
la tête de matignon parce que il y a
semble-t-il une certaine impudeur
souvent que l'on associe à ce terrain là
elle arrive à ali va plusieurs reprises
devant ruth elkrief sur lci tf1 encore
mais aussi dans le magazine elle elle
pouvait pas laisser passer évidemment la
deuxième première ministre de france
dans la république don kelly va dans l
est l ivac façon un peu plus original là
à la rentrée le 30 août dernier dans le
groupe tmc sur une émission de
divertissement d'infodivertissement
quotidien écoutez bien ce que dit et
benson peut-être à titre plus personnel
j'ai un fils qui a 30 ans voilà que
évidemment j'admire beaucoup
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire vous
demander ce qu'il fait dans la vie alors
il fait du droit
et puis peut-être je suis bosseuse je
pense que c'est dans mon caractère c'est
la réputation vous avez oui je pense que
c'est vrai au fait comme jury sportive
sportive voilà je suis une fan de romans
de cinéma de théâtre et comme soupape
c'est l'humour et je pense que vous
n'avez pas remarqué mais la cigarette
électronique
oui
c'est casse gueule ce type d'exercice
pas du tout alors vous avez remarqué que
c'était le groupe tf1 encore donc il
faudra les webcams du côté de l'exécutif
pourquoi cet amour pour tf1 c'est pas du
tout cas ce que l'on pourrait croire
qu'il ya des pièges et cetera pas du
tout c'est du velours pour des
politiques c'est un boulevard pour pour
la communication parce que vous l'avez
vu il ya une très bonne ambiance il y à
0 piège ya pas de questions qui vont
vraiment braquer le politique et donc on
y va quand on veut de la notoriété et
quand on veut de la popularité vous avez
raison c'est ce qui lui manquait quand
on veut aussi casser un peu certains
clichés comme sa dureté vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs vous même dans une zone a dit
la brutalité c'est vrai que c'était des
mots qui vont des adjectifs qui allait
quitter lui était associé et là elle a
essayé de tout casser prochaine
interview vous avez raison c'est lundi
donc là elle y va pour un autre sujet
beaucoup plus lourd mais je crois
qu'elle a compris comment fallait
communiquer et donc elle va continuer à
la fois sur le terrain de l'as un peu
martial it et on va dire ça est martial
elle va montrer qu'elle est le chef du
gouvernement mais aussi qu'elle va
montrer sa personnalité de femme est
aussi sa personnalité uniquement de
citoyenne
merci beaucoup pour cette analyse je
reviens à un moment à sur le poids de
l'opinion publique jean daniel vous nous
avez parlé un peu de l'image qu'elle
voulait avoir quand on regarde les
sondages de popularité
s'est pas trop mal ça a été un peu
difficile au début mais ça s'est
amélioré c'est surtout supérieur à la
popularité du président la république
c'est un classique st non c'est pas
classique l'a pratiquement au même
niveau en fait que le président de la
réplique on a pu voir en fait qui peut y
avoir deux par moments des dissonances
assez importante et qui peuvent exister
entre le président l'impliquer le
premier ministre à l'époque de françois
hollande c'était le cas on a pu voir des
moments où on avait des premiers disques
étaient bien plus populaires ou qui
générait une confiance qui était plus
importante que le président de la
république ça a pu être le cas à la fin
pour edouard philippe ça a été le cas à
un moment également pour françois fillon
lorsque nicolas sarkozy a été président
des appliques il ya aussi un phénomène
qui est un phénomène je crois assez
nouveau c'est la manière dont les
français peuvent réagir à l'égard des
messages médiatiques dont laetitia
faisait hôtel faisait référence on a eu
nous l'a souvent fait des médias qui
dans un premier temps aux tendances à
encenser les responsables politiques un
peu à 110 tendre et après parfois les
critiquer fortement et la d3 il ya un
des termes que je voulais pas utiliser
donc il ya un des points en fait
aujourd'hui en fait où on a commencé
déjà par des médias qui ont été
extrêmement sévère avec avec elisabeth
board en la traitant d' incompétent
temps les traite ou de plan b en
considérant au fait qu'elle n'avait pas
un profil politique qu'elle avait un
côté qui était extrêmement technique
n'était pas adapté à la situation et la
lecture médiatique qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui quand même quelque peu
inversée
et on fait une émission
est en fait d'un regard qui est un
regard on va dire relativement critique
avec pour faire vite une forme de procès
en incompétence et qu'il eut été établi
aujourd'hui avec justement la question
de la compétence ou de la méthode des
lieux de vente qui n'est pas d'ailleurs
la méthode des manuels macro et qui
aujourd'hui est relayé les français
malgré tout sont sensibles à ce bruit
médiatique parce que elisabeth borne
aujourd'hui n'a pas forcément de ligne
politique qui lui apparaît comme étant
extrêmement clair elle n'a pas
d'histoire politique préalable qui lui
permettent d'arriver auréolé justement
de ce regard d'un point de vue d'opinion
donc on va regarder des aspects qui sont
absolument loin d'être annexes c'est la
question la méthode on sait que c'est
souvent dessus d'ailleurs qui emmanuel
macron avait été critiqué sur un côté
terriblement descendants autoritaire
jupitérien dont parfois ils pouvaient se
vanter et qui met quelque peu
contrebalancé avec la manière dont les
abeilles bornes joue aujourd'hui son
rôle en tant que premier ministre et
donc je pense qu'il va falloir regarder
deux choses c'est non seulement la
monnaie des français vont être amenées à
évoluer mais également la manière dont
le message médiatique d'un point de vue
global va être émis est-ce qu'on va
considérer encore dans quelques semaines
dans quelques mois que la méthode borne
est une méthode qui qui qui fonctionne
et ça aura une incidence sur le pineau
des français à son égard alors moi ya
une chose qui m'a marqué c'est qu'elle a
pris soin de se rendre à la rentrée
politique d'edouard philippe à
fontainebleau elle était aujourd'hui à
la rentrée du modem dans le morbihan
elle a évidemment fait celle de son
parti renaissance est-ce qu'elle l'est
ou est ce qu'elle peut devenir la chef
de la majorité c'est le message
effectivement qui est visé en se rendant
dans ses différentes rentrée politique
de se poser comme chef de la main je
t'ai normalement c'est effectivement la
fonction où l'une des fonctions
principales du premier ministre et sa
fonction c'est à dimension la plus
politique du premier ministre est pas
toujours le cas à ce jour franchement le
ciel de son prédécesseur jean quelles
excuses de jean castex qui était sur un
autre registre mais aussi dans un autre
contexte là c'est une question qui est
tout à fait fondamental parce qu'il n'y
a pas de majorité absolue et donc l'idée
de mettre du liant de mai de la
coordination dans la majorité d'éviter
les situations de clash de quoi qu'on a
quand même vu depuis quelques heures que
des membres très important de la
majorité françois bayrou mais aussi la
président de l'assemblée nationale est
assurément c'est à dire sur sur la
retraite
il faut pas fonctionné comme ça donc là
le premier ministe normalement doit
endosser effectivement le costume
d'animateur de coordonnateur de la
majorité pour éviter et mettre de
l'huile dans les rouages ans que ça
coince trop alors c'est vrai que de ce
point de vue là elle est pour le moment
pas vraiment identifié pour comme étant
quelqu'un qui veut dire les épaules
politique a déjà montré qu'elle savait
faire ça elle l'a montré dans sa vie
professionnelle
par contre dans la vie politique à la
pas encore été exposées à cette question
et c'est sans doute peut-être un d un
des rouages pour 1 de progression de la
popularité pour imposer le style et la
méthode parce que pour le moment c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas vraiment quelque
chose qui aux yeux de l'opinion est
aussi évident que cela jean daniel le
rappelait tout à l'heure c'est quelque
chose que les français demandent qu'à
découvrir on découvre une personnalité
en rcr qui aimait retards dus en partie
toujours les personnalités dans les
moments difficiles quand ta personnalité
d'une certaine manière acculé dans ses
retranchements doit affirmer qu' elle et
c'est dans ces moments là que des
personnalités
s'affirment et là pour le moment on a un
peu une petite incertitude on voit bien
quel type de personnalité elle peut être
rassurez-vous les ennuis ont réglé assez
vite voir édition du rallye situation
difficile des situations difficiles et
les situations difficiles voilà m les
personnalités politiques un peu au pied
du mur pour s'affirmer et surtout
laisser une trace dans l'opinion qui est
un véritable marqueur et pour le moment
je trouve qu'on a pas chez elle encore
c'est qu'une question de temps sans
doute n'en a pas encore chez elle là le
truc qui fait que tout le monde
identifie un s'entraînant son style à
son sillage on a le style castex il est
instantanément identifiables par les
français une forme de bonhomie son
accent et c'est le style edouard
philippe s'est imposé très vite lui
aussi pour le moment chez chez les abats
voilà il faut qu elle il faut qu'elle
montre aux français sa fameuse méthode
la coordination les coudes des autres
pour que s'affirme davantage nathalie
second vous parliez de de bruno le maire
de gérald darmanin tout à l'heure qui
sont ses rivaux est ce que ce sont
essentiellement ces deux là et qui sont
ses alliés est ce qu'il ya des bornes
east donc pas encore est là ou si elle a
quand même dans la majorité
ce qu'on appelle les députés de l'ailé
gauche de la majorité renaissance il ya
quand même un sacha ollier est
clairement son allié ils sont un certain
nombre à à la soutenir à prendre sa
défense dans les médias au gouvernement
il ya des gens qui l'a choisi ils ont
tous été imposée par l'elysée je pense
qu'elle a choisi effectivement lié du
soft au travail
elle a même choisi son directeur de
cabinet qui est un ancien collaborateur
qui étouffe un ancien directeur
collaborateurs à elle qu'elle est
extrêmement confiance elle lui a imposé
comme directeur de cabinet du soap elle
a choisi son directeur de cabinet à l
cabinet effectivement parler de dan de
bayser et finalement si royal au sommet
je pense qu'il a les épaules pour les
téléspectateurs c'est l'elysée qui a
choisi le directeur de cabinet d
isabelle borne qui a choisi elle même le
directeur de cabinet d'olivier dussopt
ceci dit aurélien mousse où il est il
vient de la gauche aussi
je pense pas qu'ils lui pose de problème
puisque ça
elle béchu effectivement elle l'a pas
choisie mais mais je pense qu agnès
manière honnête et si
voilà l asse qui sait ses rivaux sont
clairement ce qu'ils sont très
identifiée à droite mais le reste est
quand même et quand même assez assez
conciliant et a envie qu'elle réussisse
enfin alors on va dire un mot de la
méthode d'elisabeth bornes lors de son
discours de politique générale à laver
programme prononcé je crois plus d'une
demi-douzaine de fois le mot compromis à
peu préparés pour le mot concertation ça
c'est elisabeth bornes qui se présentait
comme premier ministre et puis allez
isabelle borne qui est venu montrer sa
détermination au député renaissance
c'était au début du mois en
seine-et-marne regardez mais nous
n'avons pas à avoir peur car nous ne
nous laisserons pas enfermer dans la
tentation de l'immobilisme
à cette volonté systématique de blocage
affirmer sans beaucoup de nuances nous
répondrons par notre détermination et
par le respect de nos institutions qui
ont prévu comment organiser notre
démocratie dans ces situations
alors il ya deux elisabeth bande celles
qui cherchent la concertation le
compromis est celle qui dit je vais pas
me laisser enfermer dans l'immobilisme
j'avance vous allez déterminer là en
tout cas dans cet extrait elle un peu
verticale quand même un ennemi c'est
l'immobilisme et nous on a les
institutions avec nous on va y aller on
va continuer notre chemin réformateur
donc effectivement c'est aussi la
fonction qui veut ça a le premier
ministre il est quand même là pour
mettre en musique le programme du
président est le programme du président
il n'a pas expliqué il expliqué qu'ils
ont un changement de méthode emmanuel
macron me lapp a expliqué qu'il avait
fondamentalement des changements
d'objectifs
c'est la méthode qui veut qu qui veut
changer donc là elle est dans son rôle
il ya une feuille de route des élections
présidentielles la réforme des retraites
à à conduire et elle ne veut pas c'est
s'enfermer dit-elle dans l'immobilisme
alors c'est vrai qu'il reste à voir
comment la nouvelle méthode elle
concilie le fait de ne pas être dans
l'immobilisme le fait de concerter
de tenir compte du point de vue des
autres ailiers un test crash qui est
effectivement la réforme des retraites à
venir ça fait faire l'objet
d'ajustements
dans son discours de politique générale
elle a dit un mot un autre mot qu'elle a
répété beaucoup de fois je sais plus 50
fois je croise et nous devons le mot de
voir ce que les gouvernants doivent aux
peuples doivent gouverner et ça c'est
populaire ça c'est ce qui manque dans
cette crise de la démocratie que nous
vivons tous ce lien qui visiblement est
rompu de confiance entre les gouvernés
et ceux qui nous gouvernent ce sens du
devoir de celui qui a le pouvoir envers
le peuple est fondamentale et ça elle
n'a vraiment rien peut être interprété
dans ce sens là c'est tout à fait vrai
et puis il peut aussi nous devons n'y a
pas le choix
verticales est-ce que ça s'est traduit
en acte nathalie c'est cette volonté de
concertation cette volonté on va parler
du dossier des retraites là mais cet été
est ce que vous avez vu une isabelle
borne qui cherchait ce compromis où
c'était que des mots elle a quand même
chercher elle elle a obtenu alors
c'était sur le pouvoir d'achat sur la
loi pouvoir d'achat elle a obtenu des
elle a réussi à faire passer son texte
donc
c'était facile c'était le sucre et
c'était comme ils disent dans l'âme
acronis étaient des textes où il était
facile d'avoir un consensus
les discussions avec l air
beaucoup aidé maintenant c'est une autre
paire de manches enfin on est là on
rentre dans le dur c'est pas vraiment ce
qui s'est passé c'est en juillet
vraiment à mon avis représentatif de ce
qui va se passer pendant le reste du
quinquennat jordan et elle est ce que
les français sont demandeurs de ce
compromis de cette conciliation de ces
espèces de si tous les gars du monde
voulait se donner la main ou est ce que
c'est une chimère politique auquel ils
ne croient pas beaucoup
ils ont d'une manière ou d'une autre en
fait des considérations politiques
qu'ils soient assez marquées et tous
ceux en fait qui ont dit les français
ont constitué la somme nationale
pourquoi tout le monde se réunissent et
des halles au gouvernement mon avis faut
une analyse un peu de wishful thinking
cotillons bon français c'est à dire de
il aimerait bien que ça se passe comme
ça mais au final les électeurs qui ont
voté pour le ratio national ce qu'ont
voté pour la nuque n'était pas du tout
c'est le même bureau politique et que
celle que ceux qui avaient voté en
faveur des candidats qui était soutenu
par le président de la réplique quoi
qu'il en soit la question la méthode est
absolument essentiel et on voit bien
nous on l'a vu par le passé que
refuser de donner le sentiment qu'une
forme de concertation qui est d' écoute
des ordinations des confédérations
syndicales qui est une écoute des
citoyens qui est une écoute de tout ce
que peut être d'une manière ou d'une
autre des corps intermédiaires dont les
formations politiques quand bien même
leur opinion serait profondément
dégradée aujourd'hui aux et des français
permet de dire on peut être en désaccord
mais au moins on a pu entendre des voix
dissonantes qui ont pu exprimer à
l'égard du gouvernement ce en quoi nous
étions au profondément en désaccord nous
on a été très marquée ça date un petit
peu du cpe qui avait été porté par
dominique de villepin en 2103 première
embauche contrat première embauche
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion avant même
la mise en place montraient que les
français globalement était prêt à
accepter les différentes mesures qui
était proposée par dominique de villepin
dont le fait que des jeunes soient
pillés - plasmique le fait que le
premier de l'époque a fait voter en
urgence la loi à l'assemblée nationale
c'est à dire sans qu'ils aient
véritablement de débats le fait qu'il
n'ait pas reçu les confédérations
syndicales à fécamp quinze jours de
temps en dehors de la question de
mobilisation
opinion qu'étaient les opinions
positives sont transformés en opinion
négative avec les dom le passage en
force donc en fait les français dit oui
à une urgence à agir en faveur du
chômage oui à jullianges en sa faveur en
faveur du chômage ou en tout cas la
réduction du chômage des jeunes
globalement les réformes qui sont
proposés nous permet de donner le
sentiment que les jeunes auront un
premier pied à l'étrier mais la méthode
qui a été utilisé à donner le sentiment
que au final si on refusait d'écouter
les voix qui étaient contraire c'est que
peut-être qu'il y avait quand même un
fond de raison de la part des voix
critiques à l'égard du projet donc la
question de la méthode est
systématiquement importante est
peut-être plus en france que dans
d'autres pays alors je reviens c'est et
des concertations parce que pour
concerter pour discuter pour négocier il
faut être au moins deux il y en a un qui
ressortit est un peu dubitatif sur cette
méthode c'est andré chassaigne le patron
des députés communistes écoutez quand on
vient dans ce type de rencontre on va
avoir des précisions on veut savoir par
exemple est ce qu'il y aura des
amendements sur la loi retrait dans le
cadre du plfss est là l'impression qu'on
a c'est qu'on veut nous faire acheter un
âne dans un sac c'est à dire on sait pas
on sait pas on sait pas comment les
questionne la question des retraites va
être traité est-ce qu'elle joue franc
jeu est ce qu'elle est lisible isabelle
bande pour ses interlocuteurs clame la
lune ombrée chassés ils savent même pas
de quoi ils savent pas enfin ils ont pas
tranchée de savoir s'il reculer l'âge de
départ à la retraite s'il allonger la
durée de cotisation site c'est un mix
des deux enfin tout ça n'est pas
tranchée il lui voudrait et ils
voudraient qu'on lui met sur la table
pas tranché on ya eu quand même eu deux
ans de tractations
retraite qu'on a oublié de le voir mais
commence à se faire comprendre aux
français qui n'a toujours pas tranché
mais tout ça même en forme wii en
anglais ce système à points on n'est
plus du tout dans la même réforme on est
plus en huile 20 mais je reviens du coup
vous me dites basse est pas là qu'ils
llnl dire à andré chassaigne donc du
coup pourquoi le faire venir ses idées
en sortant ayant nous fait venir ils
exagèrent elle le fait venir pour lui
dire qu'est ce que tu penses de si on
passe par amendement est ce que tu votes
ou est ce que tu pense qu'il faut passer
par un jeu un projet de loi à doc c'est
tout c'est tout ce qu'elle veut savoir
c'est la question qu'elle leur a posé à
tous c'est pas c'est pas autre chose ils
ont sont là ils on sent qu'à la méthode
ils s'en sont pas au fond ils en sont
pas est ce qu'on met dans le dans
l'amendement ce qui est ce qui peut
paraître surréaliste parce que quand
même génial maintenant a été élu il ya
quatre mois il ya cinq mois elle est là
depuis quatre mois enfin on a
l'impression qu'il ne s'est rien passé
depuis qu'ils n'ont pas réfléchi qui
n'ont pas avancé cette réforme des
retraites il en a parlé le 17 mars ils
avaient l'air de savoir ce qu'il voulait
dormir de campagne il faut le rappeler
le passage de l'âge 64 à 65 ans et drake
a fait une promesse de campagne de 2010
est de 2017 alors à renouveler en 2022
et dont ensuite on n'entend plus parler
dans aucun discours public qui ressurgit
là le 12 septembre de vos cours d'un off
alors ça aussi c'est surréaliste
l'annoncé on fait une conférence de
presse il annonce dans un oeuf c'est à
dire que les journalistes une file avait
reçu l'association le président
république avait reçu l'association la
presse présidentielle centaine de
journalistes voilà mais dans un échange
je voulais j'aurais s'engage à ne pas le
citer donc c'est soit disant point le
site ont redonné des éléments tout le
monde le site ou si
c'est là où il a dit qu'il de qu'il
pouvait éventuellement concevoir cette
réforme des retraites par amendement par
un simple amendement au projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
peut-être même en utilisant cette arme
juridique du 49 3 qui permet de faire
adopter un texte sans vote en engageant
la responsabilité du gouvernement ça
c'est ce qu'on croyait jusqu'à ce matin
et puis ce matin il a pris l'avion
emmanuel macron il a donné l'interview
écouter ce qu'ils disent moi j'ai pris
des engagements campagne en toute
transparence et ses engagements il sonde
entre maintenant et
la 2031 maintenant le gouvernement doit
lancer une discussion avec les forces
sociales sert syndicales et patronales
avec les forces politiques et trouver
c'est son travail avec le parlement la
bonne manoeuvre est donc si on veut
faire cela on doit le faire on doit le
faire de manière transparente de manière
claire de la manière la plus apaisée
possible mais justement parce que nous
sommes en train de vivre un moment grave
pour notre pays et notre continent on
peut pas avoir une politique sérieuse
qui repose sur des mensonges
de la manière la plus apaisée possible
quand vous l'interprétez bruno cautrès
normalement c'est un message qui ne nous
passe pour dire on va faire de la
concertation on va écouter les autres
mais c'est la fin de la phrase
qu'importante où il dit dans la période
que nous la pâte que nous vivons on peut
pas non plus lanterner et différer les
décisions
d'une certaine manière c'est vrai que
tout le monde y cette réforme des
retraites ça fait des années on a
toujours entendu parler qu'il fallait
travailler davantage la réforme des
retraites ça fait deux ans plus de deux
ans qu'elle avait été
initiée et donc effectivement une grande
question pour les chefs d'état qui est
s'est engagé à faire cette réforme
pendant sa campagne il l'a répété il a
semblé hésiter sur la méthode et les
paramètres ajustée mais quand même il a
dit qu'ils auraient une réforme donc il
est un peu lui-même dans une sorte de
piège qui s'est tendu à lui-même il peut
pas non plus grenat absolument rien
faire donc l'idée la concertation c'est
aussi l'idée de son conseil national de
la refondation qui est quand même qui
est quand même là n'oublions pas que
lorsqu'il convoque ce conseil national
de la refondation l'un des arguments
importants qu'il avance et qu'il
souhaite faire partager à tout le monde
un certain de diagnostic objectif c'est
pour ça qu'à nourrir pendant la campagne
des législatives c'est sam et même
récemment lorsqu'il a lancé ce conseil
national c'est pour ça qu'à le président
de la cour des comptes qui vient de
manière rappeler à tout le monde où on
en est voilà et dont se mettre d'accord
sur ce que lui un peu déjà sac et se
mettent d'accord de manière à ce qu'on
puisse engager une discussion mais
l'intérieur d'un périmètre est quand
même pas mal définis par le chef de
l'état celui
du constat de la cour des comptes et
puis celui de son engagement de son
engagement de campagne est ce que nous
on trouve très intéressant c'est qu'il
ya un engagement de campagne pas été
retenu la part des français de la part
d' emmanuel macron c'est la réforme des
retraites c'est quasiment la seule
mesure qui a été qui a été vu quand vous
regardez l'électorat qui a voté dès le
premier tour en faveur d' emmanuel
macron et comment prenez les cinq
premières motivations de vote vous ne
trouvez pas la réforme des retraites
comme constituant un des points de
soutien à l'égard du président applique
en revanche du côté l'électorat d'un
côté de jean-luc mélenchon et de l'autre
de marine le pen vous voyez de la
question des retraites apparaître nos
parents pour m'en contre en 10 ans on
est contre la proposition qui a été
effectuée de la part d' emmanuel macron
tout se passe comme si il n'avait pas
tellement engrangé de soutien derrière
en fait justement cette option de
réformes en revanche il a avant même
qu'ils aient la processus de coagulation
créer des actions mesure repoussoir turc
a été une mesure absolument repoussoir
donc ça c'est sûr le point auquel on est
encore aujourd'hui ou même on voit bien
travailler différentes enquêtes c'est
qu'on n'a pas les français qui tous les
matins à travers leurs préoccupations
leurs sujets ou en tout cas ce qui leur
apparaît comme étant urgence ce qu il
faut agir qui vont nous parler de la
question des retraites donc on a cette
forme de dissonance entre l'expression
de la part du président l'appliquent le
soutien dont il peut avoir de la part du
coeur de son électorat hélas ma lentille
devons considérer qu'il s'agit d'une
mesure prioritaire et ce qui constitue
un chiffon rouge de la part d'un certain
nombre d'oppositions le seul point que
nous regardent avec attention c'est
l'électorat plutôt à droite sur
l'échiquier politique sud qui sont
proches des républicains et qui sont
sensibles justement à la thématique des
retraites autour de deux axes 1
travailler plus longtemps est de faire
en sorte qu'il puisse y avoir une forme
d'uniformisation entre le public et le
privé il y avait déjà en fait des
premières étapes qu'a été effectué et la
part d' emmanuel macron de manière un
peu détournée concernant le statut des
cheminots mais qui constituent aussi des
points qui au final peut faire que
l'électorat de droite se disent tiens
des réformes ont été faites par emmanuel
macron et des réformes qui n'ont pas été
faites par la droite lorsqu'elle était
aux responsabilités alors on sait que
toutes les oppositions sont contre ce
qu'elle appelle ce passage en force
l'hypothèse
contre parlais tout à l'heure celle de
l' amendement au plfss plus
éventuellement du 49 3 même dans la
majorité ça fait tousser françois bayrou
a dit qu'il était contre lui aussi ce
passage en france le patron des députés
modem dit qu'ils voteraient contre et
aujourd'hui c'est vrai il ya une branche
privée la présidente on en parlait de
l'assemblée nationale a même émis des
doutes sur cette méthode qu'elle ne
partage pas est ce qu'on sait nathalie
seconde ce qu elisabeth bornes souhaite
elle alors c'est toute la question est
là pris quant à soins depuis le début
très habilement de ne pas dire son
opinion ce que ce que disent
certains ministres importants qui sont
qui en ont beaucoup parlé avec elle
c'est qu'elle est rentrée dans cette
dent cette semaine de concertation de
discussions avec les syndicats avec les
forces politiques sans avis préconçues
sur la méthode pas sur le fond elle et
elle est à elle à les congeler
nécessaire cette réforme qu'il faut la
faire dans ce sens là est ce terrain
mais sans opinion préalable sur ce qu'il
faut passer par l'amendement ou est-ce
qu'il faut passer par le projet de loi
haddock donc l écoute énormément elle
est très attentive après son entourage
insiste beaucoup sur le fait que le
dialogue le consensus la recherche de
consensus c'est dans son adn qu'elle a
toujours fait ça etc et certains leur
par exemple quelqu'un comme bruno
retailleau il l'a dit ce matin il dit
moi je sens qu'elle
elle elle ne plaidera pas auprès du
président pour le passage par la maman
il la sent il la voit pas plaider pour
saïda idée
d'où l'importance de ses relations avec
avec emma d'accord le président lac rond
parlons-en justement parce qu'il a
confié élisabeth bord d'une autre
mission d'importance celle d'assurer la
transition écologique c'est même
quasiment le chantier principal et
unique de ce quinquennat mais pour le
coup c'est lui aujourd'hui qui est allé
cette jugé ce rôle en inaugurant le
premier parc éolien en mer à saint
nazaire on en parle avec tam tran huy
bonsoir bonsoir à tous
donc en gros c'est emmanuel macron qui
se gardent le gros des annonces oui
aujourd'hui il a annoncé qu'on allait
accélérer sur les énergies renouvelables
il faut dire qu'il ya besoin ça prend 10
12 ans en france entre la prise de
décision et la mise en place d'un parc
éolien offshore comme celui de saint
nazaire qu'il visitait donc aujourd'hui
et pour emmanuel macron c'est un
problème c'est beaucoup trop long
écoutez il ya une loi qui va arriver
mais aussi mobilisation de
l'administration j'ai évoqué ce sujet
devant le préfet il ya quelques jours à
l'elysée qui est clé je veux à cet égard
qu on aille deux fois plus vite au moins
pour les projets renouvelables face à la
crise énergétique les problèmes de
souveraineté qui ont été démontrés par
la crise en ukraine la crise climatique
qui prouve que plus que jamais nous
devons produire une énergie décarbonée
et bien le gouvernement mise donc sur le
nucléaire ça on le sait mais aussi sur
le renouvelable objectif sur l'éolien
flottant puisqu'il en était question
aujourd'hui construire 40 gigawatts
d'éolien en mer à l'horizon 2050 soit
environ 50 parc et pour ça et moniales
macro mise sur un nouveau en même temps
accéléré et concertée et non ce n'est
pas incompatible at il précisé tout à
l'heure en annonçant à la fois une
stratégie nationale concertée et un
projet de loi d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables qui sera présenté
lundi en conseil des ministres il y en
aura beaucoup détectrices pogné honshu
la transition énergétique a lancé une
série de concertations encore encore des
concerts y sont la marque de fabrique de
ce gouvernement qu'est ce que ça a donné
avec des parlementaires écoutez une fois
n'est pas coutume lorsqu'on parle des
relations entre le gouvernement et le
sénat et bien les sénateurs étaient
satisfaits ils ont vu la ministre la
semaine dernière ils ont vu la ministre
hier et ils ne tarissent pas d'éloges
ans et pascal aura dit le futur
rapporteur du texte didier mandelli qui
est l air se dit je le cite convaincu de
la méthode nous avons eu de bons
échanges il a constaté avec bonheur que
ses remarques avaient été prises en
compte et de l'autre côté du prisme même
son de cloche chez l'écologiste ronan
dantec qui salue lui la volonté de
trouver un consensus national autour
d'un développement des énergies
renouvelables c'est ce qu'ils ont confié
aux journalistes de public sénat tout va
pour le mieux dans le meilleur des
mondes ça serait trop facile pas
vraiment parce que si la ministre prend
autant de précautions avec la chambre
des territoires c'est aussi parce que
dans les énergies renouvelables via
l'éolien c'est un sujet explosif pour
les collectivités surtout l'éolien
terrestre un sujet très sensible pour
les mères pour les sénateurs de la
majorité sénatoriale de droite et du
centre qui ont votés régulièrement un
droit de veto afin que les édiles puis
s'opposer à l'implantation d'une
éolienne des réticences qu emmanuel
macron avait déjà pris en compte lors de
son discours de belfort halle c'était en
février dernier il avait reculé sur les
objectifs face à cette levée des
boucliers mais aujourd'hui bien il a une
petite phrase qui va peut-être pas
plaire à tout le monde cette phrase
c'était on devra quand même faire de
l'éolien terrestre il faudra concertée
et ouvrir le jeu parce qu'on a concentré
l'implantation qui ont très peu de
territoire merci dame donc concerté mais
faire quand même
oui je vous conseille juste à ceux qui
ont des smartphones le petit instagram
de emmanuel macron celles qui
communiquent directement donc il est
face à son smartphone explique tout ça
pourquoi l'éolien et cetera avec des
mois à beussent parce qu'il s'adresse à
un public nouveau les jeunes qui vont
instagram enfin nous on instagram aussi
et snap chat etc etc je viens de
regarder sur twitter il n'a pas posté
donc vous voyez il ya vraiment des
communications très différentes sur le
même sujet en fonction des supports je
reviens au couple exécutif
emmanuel macron elisabeth bande et va
devoir forcément marquer son territoire
un moment ça veut dire se démarquer ou
en tout cas à tout cas déjà c'était la
respecter c'était déjà l'idée du chef de
l'état que le futur détenteur du poste à
matignon quel qu'il soit on l'a sorti
l'élection présidentielle soit
particulièrement investi de cette
mission sacrée la transition climatique
énergétique d'où la nomination de deux
ministres et c'était ça qui était quand
même l'idée avait une déclaration
extrêmement solennelle du chef de l'état
sur cette question que le premier
ministre ou la première miss devrait
injecter de l'environnement du climat
dans toutes les branches des politiques
publiques senti sans doute sont-ils à la
loure âge là dessus mais c'est vrai que
là encore on a du mal pour le moment à
visibiliser c'est vrai que la première
ministre et elle doit normalement s'il
ya longtemps tenir cette feuille de
route elle doit normalement fortement
incarné ça c'est un sujet qu'elle
connaît
mais on s'attend à ce que normalement
elle capte un petit peu la lumière sur
ce sujet puisque le chef d'état a voulu
que le premier ou la première mini soit
particulièrement en charge de 2,2 de ça
les français soutiennent l'éolien c'est
l'éolien offshore notamment l'éolien
terrestre c'est déjà beaucoup moins
soutenu
mais il reste effectivement a beaucoup
de progrès à faire il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétude au niveau local le principe
général tout le monde trouve formidable
c'est du cd ellis qui vous rassure ce
n'est pas sur ce sujet qu'elle marquera
son territoire auquel prend bien avec
des contradictions de l'exécutif sur ce
sur ce sujet qu'il faut aussi que
l'exécutif dans son ensemble chef de
l'état à premiers messieurs gère ses
terres comment on fait passer en même
temps le message de la transition du
renouvelable
et puis du nucléaire du retour très fort
du nucléaire donc comment tout ceci se
concilie ou pas est-ce que les gens qu
une très grande sensibilité écologiste
sont très contents de voir le retour du
nucléaire bah voilà donc il ya un
certain nombre de cours de
contradictions et pour le moment là
aussi là dessus on n'a pas un affichage
encore très très très clair des
priorités dans quel ordre ça se fait et
j'en ai je
déjà puisqu'il vient dire à bruno
cautrès parce qu'en fait on a une image
parfois un peu déformée du rapport des
français à l'éolien on a une majorité de
français qui est favorable à l'éolien
d'un point de vue général et on a même
été amenés à travailler à l'éolien
terrestre est même lorsqu'on a été amené
à travailler auprès des personnes qui
vivent dans un périmètre de 5 km autour
d'un champ d'éoliennes le niveau
d'appréciation est à peu près identique
à celui qui existe de la part de ceux
qui sont pas directement concernés par
les odeurs alors évidemment
évidemment là où ça s'est passé c'est
les endroits on va tout ça s'est passé
sans problème jusqu'à présent
c'est-à-dire où il n'y avait pas
d'opposition majeure de la part des
citoyens mais on entend très fortement
les personnes qui sont critiques mais où
on a peu et ça sert et c'est logique de
personnes qui vont se mobiliser pour
commettre un champ d'éolien à côté d'eux
bien malgré tout une acceptation passive
au nom de il faut bien faire quelque
chose ici c'est ma contribution à la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
je reviens les ablettes bornes et macro
ils s'entendent bien et personnellement
et professionnellement je pense qu'ils
ont pas beaucoup de relations autres que
professionnelles honnêtement j'ai jamais
entendu parler d'une proximité
particulière c'est d'ailleurs ça jamais
été le cas entre emmanuel macron et ses
premiers ministres
en tout cas elle a réussi à imposer les
déjeuner en tête à tête
dont le précédent quinquennat on
entendait dire que c'est peut-être un
peu excessif mais que emmanuel macron
n'était pas insensible à son autorité
qu'il l'est il faisait attention à la
façon dont ils lui parler et il la
respecte en tout cas il est il est là
elle est quand même là c'est un vrai
test ces jours ci les jours qui viennent
pour elisabeth bornes parce que on sait
que et minute emmanuel macron lui est
favorable à aller vite et c'est lui qui
a mis dans le débat l'histoire de
l'amendement oms il l'a dit aux
commissaires aux finances il dit il j'ai
pas d'autres solutions si on fait pas
maintenant on le fera jamais et c'est
elle elle a reçu des oppositions qui à
part aux naissances et horizons sont
opposés à l'amendement donc si si si
malgré tout le choix qui est fait c'est
de passer par un amendement ça voudra
dire que cette concertation n'aura servi
à rien ça voudrait dire que le cnr est
mort ce sera quelques bugs et
qu'elle n'a fait qu'exécuter finalement
que tout cela n'a été qu'une animation
que de la com pour en fait maquillée
habillée une décision qui était déjà
prise à l'avance
et donc et ensuite elle aura ils auront
le problème disent qu'ils seront battus
à l'assemblée ils seront battus en
commission ils seront battus dans
l'hémicycle ils sont mis en minorité
forcément et si un vote si elle vote
d'une motion de censure marine le pen
annoncé aujourd'hui qu'elle voterait
quel que soit le parti qui la dépose
donc ce qui pourrait contrarier très
sérieusement les plans de l'exécutif
merci à tous pour avoir participé à ce
débat c'est la fin de ce premier débat